[Musique]
descendez
ce sont les
vacances d'été par excellence pour les résidents de la Colombie-Britannique,
nous sommes situés dans une vallée, donc il y a
beaucoup de terres que nous pouvons connaître
explorer
les populations
[Musique]
les gens viennent ici parce que c'est le meilleur
temps de  dans tout le Canada
[Musique], de
fin juin à fin août, la
température moyenne était de 28
à 30 degrés Celsius tous les jours de la
semaine.
Je veux dire, il n'y a rien de mieux qu'un
environnement naturel d'une beauté spectaculaire, nous avons une
scène agricole très florissante.  les vergers de pommiers
les pêches les poires pour les gens qui
aiment la gastronomie et le vin c'est l'endroit
[Musique]
la région viticole est devenue complètement
folle
le vin est l'un des meilleurs que vous puissiez
trouver au monde comme s'il devenait, vous
savez, le  région viticole du Nord
principes
[Musique]
avant tout c'est le lac le lac
est très apparent il est très beau il est
très grand il offre beaucoup d'
activités récréatives
[Musique]
silhouette [
Musique]
encore [
[Musique]
ça bouge  Je vois trois bosses, papa prend
des photos,
c'est le début de l'évolution du
requin au dinosaure
et cette créature est toujours en vie, elle est
censée survivre, elle peut nager, elle peut voler, elle
peut respirer sous l'eau, elle peut marcher sur
terre, elle a la capacité de se cacher.  c'est
incroyable ça ne ressemble pas à un poisson
ça ne ressemble pas à un serpent il fait
parfois 25 pieds de long 30 pieds de long
il a tendance à avoir une couleur verdâtre c'est
ce dont les gens parlent et il a le
visage ou l'histoire c'est qui a le  la tête
d'un cheval, une
énorme chose noire est sortie de l'eau,
probablement à 40 ou 50 pieds, le
genre gluant, brillant comme trois quatre pieds hors
de l'eau et gros
[Musique]
Je veux dire, ce n'est pas un poisson
c'est
[Musique]
Je veux dire, nous devons admettre que c'est un
nom plutôt mignon avec tous les O
dedans, presque comme Mississippi mais c'est
Ogopogo
ogopogue
[Musique]
mon père l'avait vu lui-même oh oui, il l'
avait vu  c'est lui-même euh j'ai ma
grand-mère m'a raconté des histoires je
crois qu'il est possible qu'il y
ait quelque chose comme un nogo Pogo dans
notre lac, ce dont les gens parlent varie vraiment
parfois les gens ne voient pas
du tout l'animal mais ils voient que c'est un
étrange
tu sais un bec dans l'eau ou un
mouvement étrange dans le lac j'adorerais
le voir je le cherche tout le temps Ogopogo
a été presque comme cette
créature mythique qui, euh, tu sais, par laquelle tout le monde
est fasciné en
tant qu'homme de journal, je  Je veux dire, vous
détestez presque le dire, cela vend des journaux si
j'entends parler d'une observation de Vogel Pogo, cela
fait la une à chaque fois que nous sommes
ensemble.
Je m'appelle Alan Gartrell. Je vis à
Penticton depuis 1944. J'ai vu la
Bête,
je vais le dire.  J'étais près de Mata pour prendre
un café
chez Ray Piper, c'était le
18 février 1984. Il n'y
avait pas de vent,
le lac était comme du verre
et il a regardé le lac et il a
dit qui est l'idiot là-bas
avec ce bateau rapide  période de l'année
et je l'ai regardé et j'ai dit que ce n'était pas un
hors-bord, j'ai dit que c'était une tête hors de
l'eau,
il avait un long cou, probablement
environ 14 à 16 pieds de cou dessus,
j'ai commencé à le regarder avec mes
jumelles et
Quand j'ai commencé à le regarder, Dove et il a
poussé avec ses quatre nageoires, je suis
descendu au fond du lac, j'ai fait un
cercle là-bas et je suis remonté jusqu'au
centre et j'ai enlevé le poisson à environ
10 pieds du haut de l'eau.
il l'a fait 17 fois pour nous, nous avions une vraie
séance photo devant nous et nous
n'avions pas d'appareil photo
juste d'après ce que j'ai vu, on aurait dit qu'il avait
la puissance de deux bêtes de somme, c'est très
fort
dans mes livres, il doit probablement peser
1500 livres
c'est gros
c'est un corps de 12 ou 13 pieds sur ses
palmes doivent mesurer au moins six pieds
de long
personne n'a la chance de voir quelque chose
comme ça
J'ai emmené mon beau-frère et ma fille
sur la plage en kayak 2009
donc  Je fais demi-tour sur ce rebord d'eau Wonder
et l'eau est un peu
agitée mais il y a cette
créature orange sous mon kayak aussi grosse que mon
kayak de 18 pieds et elle est aussi large que longue
et je continue de pagayer parce que je  J'avais
peur que
ce soit juste là.
J'ai une photo de moi euh dans un kayak et
au-delà de moi, il y a un objet qui fait surface à
seulement un kilomètre de la plage et cet
objet
en scannant le négatif ressemblait à
une sorte d'
alligator sortant de  l'eau était en quelque
sorte avec la bouche ouverte
I J'avais très peur
quand j'ai fait mon premier réglage en 78 I à
ce moment-là j'étais un j'étais
sceptique je dois admettre que
je
[Musique]
j'allais travailler je  j'habitais du
côté ouest à l'époque et je descendais
du côté ouest du pont et alors que je
traverse le pont jusqu'à Kelowna vers
l'est, je regarde,
je ne pouvais pas croire qu'il y avait quelque chose
dans l'eau et c'était  Je voyageais
parallèlement au pont alors j'ai arrêté ma
voiture, j'ai
arrêté ma voiture, j'ai allumé les feux
clignotants et bien sûr, il y avait du
trafic qui descendait la colline derrière moi,
ils sont tous venus et se sont garés derrière moi, je sors
par-dessus la balustrade et ce que j'ai.  Je vois
trois bosses noires se déplaçant parallèlement
au pont en direction de Kelowna et me ressemblent à
une tête qui entre et sort
de l'eau à l'avant
et j'ai baissé les yeux, je regarde à ma droite et il
devait y avoir 40 personnes qui voyaient la
même chose.  avec les voitures toutes en marche arrière,
donc de toute façon, j'étais tout excité, puis il a
disparu et je l'ai vu pendant environ 30
secondes.
Observation des chansons
Ce que je trouve fascinant, ce sont les
pictogrammes dessinés par les
peuples des Premières Nations. Ils ont évidemment vu la
même chose que les gens voient.  aujourd'hui
et je voulais dépeindre quelque chose de
si inhabituel et de si fascinant pour eux qu'ils
voulaient le documenter. Je veux dire, c'est
l'équivalent de sortir et de
filmer des vidéos ou de prendre
des photos
étrangères
[Applaudissements]
nous avons toujours appelé le yoga Pogo
comme lequel  se traduit par l'esprit du
lac, notre peuple sait qu'il y a plus
qu'un simple lac, il y a
quelque chose là-dedans qui est vraiment
profond et vraiment significatif pour qui nous sommes
en tant que peuple
est
original
qui n'a pas été fait et donc et
donc le lac  vraiment commencé, je suis passé
d'un cadre agréable, calme et paisible à un
lac vraiment vivant, vraiment intimidant et effrayant,
euh, les vagues peuvent devenir assez hautes pour
être un lac intérieur et il faisait vraiment
sombre, très froid et le chef Kakinsula a
demandé à son peuple de lâcher les
chevaux.  de traverser le lac le plus
vite possible car il y avait
quelque chose dans l'eau qui n'était pas
respecté à ce moment-là
et pendant qu'ils faisaient ça, ils ont entendu
le sevrage du cheval
ou certains chevaux ont fini par plonger
sous l'eau et ils ont réussi à traverser  le
lac mais les chevaux avaient des cicatrices, cela ressemblait
à des marques de griffes géantes sur
leur torse, certains avaient
des marques de morsure sur leur corps
[Musique]
quand les premiers colons sont arrivés, vous devez vous
rappeler à quoi ressemblait l'Okanagan,
c'était essentiellement un pays sauvage.  c'était
comme ce que vous trouveriez si vous alliez
dans le nord de la Colombie-Britannique maintenant,
de sorte que lorsque les colons sont arrivés ici, je veux dire,
ils vivaient juste à la lisière de
la Grande Forêt, ils n'avaient aucune idée de ce qu'il y avait
ici, de ce qui n'était pas ici et des histoires sur
un  la créature du lac qu'ils ont reçue des
membres des Premières Nations leur a probablement
fait peur,
ils ont cru aux histoires des autochtones et
il y a eu de nombreux
événements effrayants de nombreuses observations
[Musique]
ils ont en fait posté des gardes armés sur les
rives du lac Okanagan pour patrouiller
les plages avec leurs mousquets euh pour
protéger leurs familles ou ils ont essayé de
le capturer en lançant des hameçons dans le
lac je veux dire, c'est la chose la plus incroyable
ce sont des gens durs je veux dire
bonjour tu sais donc ils ont dû voir
quelque chose et puis ils étaient très  très
contrariés, ils ne savaient pas quoi penser mais
de la part des peuples des Premières Nations, ils ont
dû prendre cela comme une menace sérieuse.
[Musique]
euh [
Musique]
ce lac a une histoire préhistorique et il y a
10 000 ans il était un peu plus
haut et  plus longtemps qu'aujourd'hui, donc tout
cela aurait été sous l'eau,
donc la théorie est qu'il y a de nombreuses années,
quand c'était ouvert sur la mer, Olga
Pogo est arrivée et est entrée dans le lac Okanagan pour
chasser les verres de saumon, elle s'est
retrouvée enfermée ici et puis euh gentil  de
vécu ici et en quelque sorte adaptés à l'endroit où
il était, les espèces sont soit bien adaptées
à un environnement, auquel cas elles
persistent,
soit elles ne le sont pas
et elles meurent, elles disparaissent de l'
univers de
la ouananiche et elles
fraient toujours dans les ruisseaux de la région le long de
les rivages, c'est un phénomène très intéressant
parce que bien sûr, ces poissons
provenaient du saumon rouge qui était
capable d'atteindre l'océan,
donc la question se pose de savoir s'il y a
quelque chose dans l'eau dont nous ne
savons pas, c'est très  Deep Lake
[Musique],
certains diraient que c'est une espèce très ancienne,
en d'autres termes, une espèce que l'on pensait
éteinte,
mais qui s'est avérée ne pas l'être, et d'autres
diraient que c'est Oga Pogo et les monstres du Loch Ness,
où il s'agit d'une nouvelle espèce dans le
sens où elle  C'était une espèce inconnue de la science, on
y trouve toutes sortes d'espèces
tout le temps, de nouvelles probablement chaque
semaine partout dans le monde
et vous savez pourquoi quelque chose ne pourrait-il pas vivre
ici dans le lac, pourquoi les
espèces dans cette étendue d'eau ne pourraient-elles pas vivre ici 90
des kilomètres de long, c'est incroyable, il en fait quatre,
il fait deux milles et demi de large, c'est l'un
des lacs les plus profonds d'Amérique du Nord.
Pourquoi quelque chose qui
n'a pas été trouvé
étranger ne pourrait-il pas vivre ici?
[Musique]
victime de tout cela tout le temps, c'est
parce que c'est tellement  une grande créature que
c'est un mâle, ils appellent Ogopogo comme lui
tout le temps et moi, j'en suis certainement
victime aussi, mais nos gens
racontent des histoires. J'ai vu plusieurs logos
pogos, ce qui signifie qu'il doit y avoir,
vous savez, la science prouve que c'est le cas.  être un
mâle et une femelle pour recréer
des morogopogos ou plus
et leurs histoires d'Ogopogo
sur les plages et même des appendices pour
marcher sur la terre avec
bien ceci est Pebble Beach c'est West
Kelowna juste en bas de la plage c'est l'
existence de Beachland Andrew Bennett
Maintenant, vous voyez, c'est
quand j'ai vu cette créature fuyant
les Boy Scouts, elle était très timide et s'est
enfuie très vite, elle ne
correspondait à aucune description ni à aucune image que
j'ai jamais pu trouver, ma pensée
est que ce n'est pas un  salamandre, c'est vraiment
la partie du stade de cette
créature qui consiste à naître sur terre puis à
retourner dans le
cycle de vie de l'eau et la curiosité de Groupons
[Musique] me
traversait l'esprit, il doit y en
avoir d'autres à
remercier sur place  vous
[Musique]
les images étrangères [Musique] [Musique] ressemblaient à des journaux et
puis je parcourais mes photos et
et euh réalisant ou peut-être qu'il y avait
quelque chose de plus à cela
et puis j'ai réalisé que
ce n'était pas un journal, c'était une créature
il avait évidemment une nageoire qui ressemblait à
Ogle Pogo, il était long, il ne faisait
peut-être qu'un pied de large et peut-être 18 pieds de long
et et en y regardant de plus près, vous pouviez
voir un œil, une tête de lézard et une
langue qui sortait, je ne le savais pas avant
que ça ressemblait tellement à un lézard mais en tout cas
c'est ce qui semblait ressortir sur
les images
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] il y
a un œuf et une créature qui en sort
encore en train d'éclore et puis il y
a tous ces petits tout autour
tout autour  très bien camouflé sa
couleur orange est frappée par les feuilles d'oranger et
la crevasse c'est vraiment très bien
camouflage
simulation Andrew Bosque
tu jurerais que c'était une bûche et tu
verrais ces photos tu jurerais
leurs promenades mais elles ne sont vraiment pas il y a
un oeil  il y a une narine il y a
une langue qui sort il y a là il y a
des détails qui ne sont tout simplement pas dans les journaux
euh ce camouflage a évolué sur
des millions d'années et et il est presque
parfait il peut juste rester là même un
requin a du mal à s'asseoir dedans
place pendant plus d'une demi-heure mais
cette créature peut rester là pendant des heures
et faire
semblant que c'est une bûche et puis la partie
qui vous dit que ce n'est pas une
bûche, c'est vous si vous y retournez, la bûche
a disparu
euh et et  c'est sa maison c'est là
qu'il pond ses œufs ici et
dans l'eau il vit ici ça fait
quatre ou cinq ans je pense sur de nombreuses
photos de cette région et je suis convaincu
que c'est la maison de pogo Fogo
Andrew
est
il y a quelques années, j'ai pris une photo de la
tête sortant d'une grotte au fond
du lac à environ 14 pieds sous terre et on
dirait qu'Ogle Pogo
est
[Musique]
hé Mme Susan Allison
a eu une observation et elle a vu cet objet qui
elle pensait que c'était un tronc de pin ou un
tronc d'arbre,
mais elle a ensuite vu qu'il bougeait contre
le vent. Andrews,
toute sorte de créature ressemblant à un dinosaure qui
a vécu aussi longtemps peut évidemment
détruire rapidement une personne, donc je ne
voulais pas expérimenter en la soulevant
si  cela semblait trop dangereux
[Musique]
et même si cela a son
avantage et c'est dans son camouflage, ma
crainte est que
la créature finisse par être chassée et ce
ne serait pas mon souhait, mon souhait est
que l'espèce soit en péril  j'identifierais
la créature et ensuite la protégerais
[Musique]
euh les
photos les plus récentes que vous voyez,
aucune de ces photos n'a vraiment été
scientifiquement vérifiée comme Ogopogo mais
il y a certainement vous savez, ce sont des
photos du lac que les gens ne
prennent pas tous les jours  et je ne le vois pas tous les jours,
alors
[Musique]
filmer
[Musique] ce que
nous faisions, c'est reconstituer
ce que j'ai vu pour la première fois en 1978 et bien
sûr, j'étais un peu plus jeune à l'époque, alors mon
fils m'a joué
[Musique]
et hors du  bleu, quelque chose apparaît dans
le lac, ce sont les trois bosses,
quelles sont les chances que vous sachiez que c'est comme si
c'était si rare de sceller Gapogo et il se
présente pour une équipe de tournage et nous avions tous les figurants là-bas,
l'équipe de tournage, nous avions 14
personnes là-bas, une une personne  j'ai vu ces 14
personnes regarder un mouvement
et tout le monde commence à crier et
ils tournent les caméras de télévision
vers lui,
ça bouge, je vois trois bosses,
attendez une minute, est-ce que vous filmez ça
et si le plus incroyable, c'est que
personne n'agit là-dedans  ils regardent
ça et nous avons l'audio et c'est l'
audio le plus incroyable que vous ayez jamais
entendu, vraiment de très bonnes choses, je ne
sais pas quoi dire à part que mon souffle
a été coupé, j'ai commencé à paniquer,
en gros, papa a compris  photos
Bonjour Il y avait évidemment quelque chose
là-bas qui n'était pas naturel, qui
n'était pas tout à fait une preuve mais qui était tellement
tentant que vous savez et faites en sorte que
la journée fasse la semaine faire la
production pour cette équipe de tournage, nous avons vu
quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est
L'existence était géniale, nous avions 75 personnes
impliquées, nous avons passé trois semaines sur le
lac et nous avons obtenu de très bons résultats
à
300 pieds, ce qui est tout simplement incroyable,
cette grotte était à cent pieds de profondeur, elle faisait environ
14 pieds de large et il y avait de
l'eau vraiment plus froide.  sortant de la
grotte
dans le lac à partir d'une sorte de
source souterraine ou quoi que ce
soit
[Musique]
ils ne savent pas jusqu'où va cette grotte
et Bill Staciak a dit que ses
plongeurs étaient entrés dans la grotte et qu'il y avait
trop d'eau  sortant de la
grotte
et rend trop difficile pour les plongeurs de
nager dans la grotte.
Nos plongeurs bien sûr, ils sont un
peu paniqués et ils ne sont pas allés très
loin alors qui sait ce qu'il y a là-dedans et
ce n'est qu'une seule grotte sur  le mur donc il y
a d'autres endroits dans le lac où l'
eau entre
ici,
regardez qu'ils avaient ce sonar à balayage latéral
qui est un type
de médicament sonar assez avancé, il y
a quelque chose dans l'eau dont le
son n'aurait pas été rebondi  à l'arrière,
s'il n'a pas heurté un objet, ils ont trouvé
quelque chose de deux à trois cents pieds de profondeur
dans l'eau, quelque chose d'énorme qui ne
pouvait en aucun cas être un tas de poissons
et ils ont dit que vous savez, nous ne savons pas
ce que c'est, mais il y a  quelque chose là-bas
ok
étranger
nous estimons que la cible elle-même faisait
17 mètres de long
énorme et puis a disparu ouais ouais c'était
juste là
[Musique]
nous l'avons eu sur deux balayages du sonar le
troisième balayage il est passé en dessous de notre faisceau et
nous l'avons perdu mais peu importe  c'était
énorme et c'était un retour de sonar solide et il
bougeait, il s'est déplacé de 10 degrés bâbord
à tribord,
à ma connaissance, personne n'a jamais
réellement produit de preuves scientifiques, je
veux dire, il y a eu un million de dollars et
deux millions de dollars de récompenses pour la preuve de
l'existence d'Olga Pogo et personne n'a
réclamé la récompense que nous avons eue, les gens
tout au long des années sont venus voir s'ils
pouvaient trouver quelque chose et trouver des
preuves définitives de l'existence d'
Ogopogo mais cela est resté insaisissable
ici
[Musique] il y a des
étrangers
certaines personnes disent absolument que
j'ai vu quelque chose que je ne peux pas l'expliquer
et puis il y a ceux qui disent
absolument non, c'est juste un gros poisson ou
c'est un courant ou quoi que ce soit en général,
je suis sceptique, c'est une sorte de style de vie que je
ressens  j'aime venir ici et parler
d'Ogopogo comme ça, je serai l'
équivalent du gars qui a dit à ton enfant qu'il
n'y avait pas de Père Noël
[Musique]
tu sais désolé pour ceux qui pourraient être
contrariés par ça,
il y a beaucoup de gens qui croient
qu'Ogopogo est juste  un esturgeon géant, je suppose
que cela pourrait être une sorte d'
analyse scientifique de l'Ogle Pogo, le castor,
je le comparerais à l'histoire du Père Noël
né et élevé ici, je ne l'ai jamais vu,
du moins pas quand j'étais sobre, mais je
pense  c'est une vague que
mon grand-père utilisait un esprit
[Musique]
c'est un vieux lac c'est un lac très profond
donc je suppose qu'il pourrait y avoir quelque chose
mais je pense que c'est juste un gros poisson je ne
sais pas le Pogo lui-même semble être un peu
taquin  c'est comme si je montais et
me montrais brièvement et taquinais les
touristes, puis je disparaissais et les
laissais se demander si c'était vraiment de
l'acapogo ou était-ce un poisson ou était-ce juste
une série de vagues. Les
ERS étrangers en général sont honnêtes,
ils rapportent  aussi, d'après mon expérience,
plus ou moins ce qu'ils voient,
mais en fait, c'est une conclusion erronée.
Les caméras mentent, parfois c'est parce que des
canulars délibérés
sont faits et parfois c'est parce qu'une
photo est prise qui est un peu
ambiguë et alors peut-être que les gens commencent
à y attacher de l'importance.
je viens sur ce sentier 50 à 100 fois par
an et je vois parfois des vagues inhabituelles
au milieu du lac et et un
jour je marchais et j'en ai vu une
et il y avait quatre personnes qui arrivaient
derrière moi et je me suis arrêté et  J'ai dit qu'est-ce que
tu penses de ça là-bas et ils se
sont arrêtés et ils ont dit oh wow, c'est un
énorme animal là-dessous
et j'ai dit bien ou c'est juste une
vague stationnaire et un
lac calme, il y a
beaucoup de scientifiques qui disent
que c'est juste ça  les vagues ok et
certainement il y a des vagues et les gens
prennent des photos de vagues les
étrangers
[Musique]
sont sceptiques mais en
même temps il y a des bosses et il y a des
têtes et ça bouge dans l'eau
est
notre lac est calme et plat et puis
tout  d'un coup tu as cette vague
venant du milieu de nulle part au
milieu du lac
maintenant d'où vient-elle c'est juste
comme au milieu ouais et c'est ce
gros truc qui roule qui pourrait ressembler à un
monstre je ne sais pas  ça doit être le
monstre ça doit juste être quoi d'autre
ça pourrait être
pendant qu'on voit une vague mais il n'y a pas de bateau
ça doit être un animal ok et bien il
y a d'autres choses que ça pourrait être il y a des
poches de méthane dans les
sédiments
et  ça libère instantanément et qui
provoque toutes sortes de bouillonnements et d'eau
et de vapeur en surface et ça a
été vu plusieurs fois et ça a aussi euh
été pris pour un décor de vocapogo
c'est autant un processus de
rationalisation que d'imagination donc par
exemple ces bûches qui bougent  les vents contraires
peuvent être causés par ce que l'on appelle des
ceintures internes de scission par lesquelles l'
eau chaude du réchauffement d'un été peut être
poussée par le vent vers une extrémité d'un lac,
puis nous refluerons à nouveau,
provoquant des vagues sous-marines, maintenant vous ne le faites pas
vraiment.  voyez ces vagues à la surface,
mais s'il y a un objet à la surface
comme un tronc d'arbre, alors il se déplacera
contre le vent
et vous avez besoin d'un peu de
science générale pour comprendre que nous savons par
la physique que
les fluides se déplaçant dans un champ gravitationnel
vont  former quelque chose appelé une
onde de gravité créée simplement à cause de la
différence de température lorsque cela
corrige l'eau commencera en fait
à former des vagues. D'
autres questions que vous pouvez également poser, il y a
une sorte de grotte sous-marine
reliant toutes ces choses, c'est
géologiquement ridicule, je veux dire, ce serait  je
dois passer sous les principaux cols de montagne
et les systèmes de poussée et les terrains volcaniques
et autres. Je veux dire, vous savez, le numéro un
et le numéro deux sont que c'est censé être un
animal respirant l'air et comment va-t-il
nager des centaines et des centaines de kilomètres
sous l'eau sans accès aux
gens de l'air  vont se moquer et rire mais
tous ceux qui ont vu quelque chose dans
le lac ont été ridiculisés mais il
faut juste l'accepter parce que c'est une chose réelle
euh les gens se moquent de moi quand je leur dis
ce que j'ai vu
mais ils vont rire autant qu'ils veulent
quoi  J'ai vu, j'ai vu le dernier gars m'a dit qu'il a
dit, tu as probablement vu ce castor
dans le lac, eh bien, il est 3 000
fois plus gros qu'un castor,
je
pense que même les dinosaures et toutes les
choses qui sont maintenant éteintes, vous avez,
vous avez  quelque chose comme ça,
vivant toujours dans un lac profond et profond comme le
lac Okanagan,
trouvant que la preuve scientifique est
quelque chose dont certaines personnes ont besoin,
euh, notre peuple, les gens de la Première Nation de Cisjordanie
pour voir les gens de cette région, euh, je
ne crois pas que vous ayez besoin de voir
quelque chose  pour y croire, nous voulons tous y
croire Je pense que c'est merveilleux d'
avoir le mythe Je pense que le Père Noël ou le yoga
Pogo est un excellent ajout à
l'histoire de Kelowna, est-ce que
j'y crois et non mais je ne vais pas
démystifier le mythe parce que je  je pense que le
mythe est amusant
merci
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la créature qui était redoutée par les
premiers colons n'est pas la créature que
nous voyons maintenant, nous voyons ce jouet vert pelucheux
dans le grand magasin donc il y a ça
créature très bénigne, ce qui n'est pas ce que
l'expérience des premiers colons a été
facile
et fondamentalement, les gens n'aimaient pas la
terre natale, le nom je suppose au
début et ils ont trouvé ce
nom Ogle Pogo à partir d'une chanson
prise dans une salle de danse britannique  est-ce que sa
mère était un perce-oreille, son père était un
et je ne me souviens plus du reste
et c'est devenu en quelque sorte le projet favori de tout le monde
et quand vous voyez cette petite
créature, elle est enfermée dans le
pied cimenté de la rue principale, euh le  les enfants
viennent partout et absolument
personne n'en a peur,
bien sûr, nous ne parlons pas de sacrifices
au monstre puisque personne n'est jamais mort
de lui ou d'elle ou quoi que ce soit,
je pense qu'il est sympathique, il a le
visage souriant et tout le reste va bien
[Musique]
bien sûr, il y a aussi un
aspect commercialisé d'Ogopogo, plus câlin,
euh, vous connaissez la version en peluche d'
Ogopogo que vous pouvez acheter dans les
centres touristiques et des trucs comme ça. Beaucoup de
gens recherchent Rogofogo et ce sont, vous
savez, des gens très sensés et je crois qu'il y a
quelque chose dans le lac, c'est un
gars sympathique, il n'a pas mangé trop de
touristes et pourtant
il ne mange pas de gens, il mange des plantes, il
mange des glaces chez ogos
[Musique]
je m'appelle Sharon Brown et j'habite dans l'
État de Penticton B où je cours  et possédons un
magasin de glaces appelé ogos ice cream,
nous avons notre glace qui porte le nom d'
Ogopogo, c'est une glace à la vanille, à la réglisse noire et à l'
orange,
très lumineuse et colorée, les enfants
l'adorent vraiment à cause de sa couleur, les
gens entrent, ils sont heureux d'être  je
viens pour une expérience heureuse et c'est un
endroit vraiment très heureux, les
gens aiment le monstre, vous connaissez le
lac Okanagan et l'Ogopogo,
c'est à quoi sert le lac,
nous avons certainement
des images d'Ogopogo tout autour de la ville, nous
avons un chaos en mosaïque, vous verrez
des entreprises  qui s'appellent Ogopogo,
quel que soit le
club Rotary, le Zenoga Pogo Swim Club,
c'est la zone Diego Pogo de la
patrouille canadienne de ski. Les visites du Club Ogopogo vous savez que
nous vous emmènerons sur le lac et
il y a une chance que vous puissiez voir Ogopogo,
c'est un excellent outil de marketing.
tes yeux s'ouvrent parce qu'on ne
sait jamais, on ne sait jamais quand il pourrait apparaître,
je veux dire, c'est, je veux dire, c'est une excellente
promotion touristique. Je possède et exploite un
bed and breakfast et ça s'appelle
les ventes, c'est devenu presque emblématique
de Kelowna, c'est utilisé dans la ville.  logo,
il est utilisé sur toutes sortes de
papeterie, c'est en quelque sorte devenu le
symbole de Kelowna, mais juste à côté,
ils voient l'Olga Pogo. C'est un
point focal pour les touristes si les gens veulent
croire qu'il y a un Oklahoma qui est génial.
J'adore cet endroit, donc c'est  amène les gens à
chercher un oglebogo bien sûr
[Musique]
local [
Musique] [
Musique]
est
[Musique]
les gens peuvent venir essayer de trouver Ogopogo
en explorant les profondeurs du lac Okanagan
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose à
craindre, c'est quelque chose à être  respecté
et il faut y croire pour vraiment en faire
l'expérience. Je pense que je
vous remercie.
Je pense que c'est plutôt sympa que
personne n'ait pu prouver ou réfuter
qu'il existe un Ogopogo. Je veux dire, les gens
aiment les histoires, les gens lisent les histoires
qu'ils sont.  Je suis de fervents adeptes d'
Ogopogo, ils aiment tu sais, ils
n'aimerais rien de mieux savoir qu'il
existe mais en même temps c'est plutôt
sympa qu'il n'y ait aucune preuve
parce que le mythe continue
[Musique]
merci il y a eu un
changement incroyable dans l'attitude des gens
à propos d'Olga Pogo et j'ai vu ça
au cours des 10 ou 15 dernières années euh il y a
moins de sceptiques maintenant euh je pense que les gens
commencent à comprendre le fait
que vous savez qu'ils pourraient être là
pourrait être un animal qui vit dans ce
lac, nous trouvons certainement de nouvelles espèces
partout dans le monde presque chaque semaine
dont nous ignorions l'existence,
c'est un grand attrait pour Kelowna et le
fait qu'il y ait en fait quelque chose
ici est tout simplement remarquable et
et ça  est sa maison c'est là qu'il
pond ses œufs ici et dans l'
eau il vit ici
cela mérite d'être protégé
est
imprévisible on ne sait jamais quand il
va apparaître et bien sûr il
va toujours se montrer quand la caméra n'est pas
prête quand le  la caméra n'est pas focalisée lorsque
vous laissez la caméra dans la voiture, il
semble toujours apparaître lorsque vous êtes le moins
susceptible de fournir la preuve de
son existence,
ils cherchent à trouver cette
preuve scientifique qu'Ogopogo existe et moi
non.  Je pense que c'est vraiment nécessaire
mais
vous savez que cela maintient l'Esprit vivant, c'est
une histoire continue,
euh, vous savez, je ne trouverai peut-être pas de
preuves scientifiques pour le prouver, mais
voilà, c'est quelque chose que je crois
dans mon cœur et ce que mes aînés
m'ont toujours appris.  que si tu crois que
c'est vrai dans ton cœur, alors ça
ne peut pas être faux
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien
[Musique]